so hey everybody my name is max Richman
I'm a quantitative analyst at Arcadia
power and the song that you just heard
is called sequel by Harry Chapin you
guys might be surprised to know when
structured query language was developed
19
I guess 44 years ago Harry Chapin was
instrumentally involved in that hence
the title of his song sequel actually no
that's not true at all
Harry was not involved with sequel
sequel is a story about actually 8 years
after he was like an attack see he has
this tacky story where he was riding
along in a taxi and he found an old
flame and a taxi for those of you that
don't know what a taxi is it's like the
worst uber you've ever been in basically
so so yeah so he's he's riding around
this taxi finds its old flame and then
eight years later writes a song called
the sequel she's actually spelled SC q
UL which is about his getting another
taxi with the same person again sue and
Sue is let's say someone that he has a
lot of feelings for but doesn't actually
get married to he gets married to
somebody called sandy and so sandy
before getting married to Harry Chapin
had like two kids one of three kids with
a letter J they were like I know
Jonathan and Jennifer and whatever and
then they had two more kids bringing it
to five and all of them had J named as
well like Jeremy and jebediah and I
don't know something like that and so it
got me thinking that I hope even though
Jared starts with a J he names all his
kids starting with an R so I'm thinking
like Reginald or Rutherford or Rihanna
or like some names that like start with
R so this is also a sequel in other ways
because I spoke at the first New York
data conference New York our conference
back in 2015 where I channeled the
spirit of R for everyone and as you
might be able to see from
tiny little Virginia Tech hat here this
is our friend Dan Chen who also wrote a
book called Python for everyone and I
just love the spirit of those books and
this conference of just like sure anyone
can get started with this let's make it
easy so I decided that I would similarly
buck the trend and not really talk about
our but talk about sequel so this is a
very gentle intro to sequel a little bit
about me I based here in DC yes I am
actually wearing the same exact shirt
bat that I'm wearing in that photo
because I am kind of like a hobo or
maybe a hippie or something I don't know
something along those lines so I've worn
a few hats I've done GIS in this
building for like five years for USAID I
found it data kind in DC which is a
great network also in New York for
volunteering your time for do data
science for good and and today I work at
Arcadia Power doing data analytics so
I'm hoping unlike Harry Chapin who
tragically died after his sequel in a
terrible car accident that I will not
that fate will not become me as I
continue beyond this sequel and I hope
that at the next our conference perhaps
like on the moon or on Mars I can do
another photo where hopefully the video
is getting like all of this and then I
can have like infinite recursion of like
the talks and the person but anyways
we'll see if we get there okay so okay
enough preamble and whatnot
what am I actually gonna really talk
about in this I'm talking about nothing
apparently
that's it no I guess it'll come back but
I'm gonna riff in the meantime it's a
pretty simple agenda we've got I'm gonna
talk a little bit about the new
renewable energy sector and then I'm
going to I also made fun of someone
yesterday for like their Dec dying and
then my tech died so and I'm going to
talk about some intro level sequel and
our characteristics
so imagine like a nice jiff like of a
spinning windmill right now cool does
anybody know what 1.5 C means anyone 1.5
C it's like a number you guys know
numbers it's number me anything
no all right well if you could imagine
lots of gifs on the screen here flailing
around showing how once we reach the
global temperature change of 1.5 degrees
Celsius we are screwed right so we have
unfortunately eclipsed that as the most
recent report from the IPCC announced
meaning that we are well on our way to a
lot of terrible effects from climate
change but what can we do about this it
feels like we're kind of powerless we
can actually do quite a bit at least
here in the US with our own activities
and what we do and we can also do some
things with our home electricity usage
so the company they work for Arcadia
power makes it easy for you to basically
opt in to make your energy usage green
and to save money so the way that that
then works is you would sign up on the
website and and automatically we would
find deals for you to save money and
connect you to solar projects use wind
to offset what you're using and whatnot
and we're also hiring like other people
and data analytics so you're interested
in kind of combining environmental
science with data science come talk to
me I now have a charming picture of
Hadley Whitcomb up here with the
obligatory motivating Henley Wickham
quote which in which he says however in
the long run I rec I highly recommend
that you at least learn the basics of
sequel it's a valuable skill for any
data scientist Hadley Wickham
in this next slide I have I I have a
sequel query just sort of laid out in
simple format we have a select statement
and which is the beginning of your query
we have an asterisk which is
representing what columns you want to
select in your query in this case all of
them and we have a from a speed of
syntax that then indicates which table
or schema you want your data to come
from and a nice little where clause
so it's really simple when you think
about it in your mind
next I have another motivating xkcd
because of course every talk needs to be
motivated by some xkcd and and in this
one we learned that the mom named oh
great I'll still like detail this cuz
it's still impossible to read it but
basically um we have little little
Bobbie tables whose mom named him Robert
single quote close paren semicolon drop
tables students which you know if you
have a Hadley Wycombe level of basic
knowledge in sequel you would chuckle at
because basically it results in to the
entire student table being dropped by
the unsuspecting elementary school so
this is why it's important to have some
you know baseline knowledge of sequel so
um let me see if there's anything else
we're showing oh yeah here's like the
thing so this thing yeah hopefully this
is somewhat familiar if not like take a
look at it it's a nice way to query data
and do stuff like that and then finally
oh yeah here's that nice picture oh yes
here's them with the death spiral so as
you can see since the dawn of
industrialization we are unfortunately
spiraling towards higher temperatures
but you can do something about it
so moving on the main topic here I'm
going to talk about our seven key areas
where you can do something in our and
you can do something in sequel and even
though maybe one you're faster than the
other it's kind of worth knowing how you
can do both of them and I'm going to
talk about the end about
you would do one or the other so at my
job we have well if I'm sorry
the first step is kind of getting set up
with environments and installing
databases and software and all of that
so at my work we use something called
Amazon redshift which is 1800 Warehouse
there are probably other data warehouses
that people use but what's really nice
is it's a columnar data storage like
with a lot of speed so it uses an older
flavor of Postgres so it's a little
wonky it doesn't have all the bells and
whistles of latest Postgres but you can
like join tons of things together like
pointlessly and you know it's really
great so we like using that we also pull
in data with stitch which is like an API
integration service or basically you can
plug in your like Facebook advertising
API you can plug in you know your
whatever third party vendor data sources
other groups and also seamlessly
integrate that into redshift to make
just like all the data together it's
really fun and then you can set up your
IDs so of course our studio is wonderful
on the our side and then on the ID side
for sequel there's sequel workbench and
a lot of other great tools for that and
once you set up with your databases and
with your tools then it's about bringing
the data in by a show of hands who's
used our ODBC before or a variant of
that oh great so good like half of the
room or more and the other half is
probably asleep but in case you weren't
asleep and you really haven't used it
that or how many people have used the DB
plier package from the hadley verse okay
about a third of people a little bit
less basically the beauty of these two
packages is that you can write sequel
directly into our and query the
underlying database that it's being
pulled from so in this case using our
ODBC you install a driver on your
machine I intentionally did not do the
Java based one because otherwise you'll
go down a Java rabbit hole and you'll
never return so raise your hand all
right yeah wow that's almost as many
people as if use Hadleys database
package which is sad okay so yeah once
you get set up there you put in all your
credentials for your database you can
just like list out your tables and then
you can run whatever queries you want to
run what kind of queries might you want
to run well just like an R you might
want to just like know what's in your
data so we have information about just
like how many rows are in this data set
so
count from the table and the schema or
an are just like tell me how many rows
there are similarly you might want to
preview some of the data like how many
columns are there what are the names of
them what kind of data do they have
inside of them you can similarly do that
and you can grab random samples and you
can look at tiny bits of it both in R
and sequel descriptive stats as well
this is where actually sometimes sequel
is kind of an advantage over it so the
table command is so simple it's nice
it's lovely you can just write table and
you can look at you know some kind of
vector and it's beautiful and it's great
but once you want to start combining a
whole bunch of them like you want to
cross 2 3 4 5 6 7 variables then you're
like oh I got install packages or
there's probably ways to do it then base
are that I'm not familiar with but these
are like it's becomes non-trivial
whereas in sequel you just keep writing
how many things you want to group things
by so for our utility company I might
want to see how many customers we have
across all 50 states with given utility
and I can just say select the utility
name and then for my next column have a
count of it so basically an aggregation
count how many there are and then group
it by that first one utility name and I
get the count by you till each of the
utility names of what I have and if I
want to add also by state then I add
state as a column I say group by one and
two and if I want to also add you know
what specifically like if a utility is
an instrument investor-owned utility or
if it's small entity I add that and you
can just keep going and quickly just get
nice cross tabs now where R is a little
bit nicer is I'm just like the
percentages so it's equal you have to do
some weird stuff where you kind of loop
things over things to get your
percentages going but you know on our
it's nice you just kind of throw prop
table up there similarly you can add
rows and columns but basically the merge
and the join are pretty much the same
you just kind of can dictate what you
want to join - what so you want to
append some data more columns you can do
a left join if you want to just limit it
to the joins the data between those two
Commons you do inner join that kind of
stuff let's see so you can also attach
more rows at the bottom so kind of
append things from the bottom and sequel
that's Union and our base our that's our
and there are other things with Indy
plier of course that you can use to do a
lot of this data manipulation and let's
say you want to create new data so my
previous talk was about are for every
survey analysis and similarly when
you're coding survey data you're just
constantly recreating new coded
variables so you can do that pretty
easily in both of these tools as well
here's where we start to get I guess a
little bit more advanced but not so
advanced is sub setting and filtering in
this example I want to see select all
the male customers from the last two
years that have either wind or solar
plans so I go ahead and type in my query
and have a bunch of filters there
similarly and besar you can do that with
this or an other way if we're doing it
in this you can also use the defier
package do some filtering and things
like that generally it's quite
performant in sequel as well so then you
have sub queries there's kind of like
this idea of nesting thing so you can do
a query within a query within a query
within a query and you might do that to
let's say aggregate something and then
join it to something that's like not
aggregated and things like that and
similarly you know you can use the
special character I'm a grid thing pipe
thing non pipe thing in our I'm sure it
has a better name and I've forgotten
here so yeah so grouping and aggregating
is that of the next big piece here as I
mentioned earlier you can just keep
adding these group bys group by every
column that you have and you can
summarize your data quite quickly
this is similar to what you can do a
deep liar in fact in deep liar there's
this neat thing called show query where
you can be like hey deep liar what would
be the sequel equivalent of what I'm
doing here
so if you like wrote something there you
could actually see what it looks like on
the sequel side and things like that and
then another nifty little I think sort
of you know all the things I've been
showing you I just compiled over a month
of just working and me like oh this is
the thing that I did this is the thing
that I did like it is really this many
things and you can do a lot with data
analytics analysis and just like
aggregation but another useful one is
called a window function in sequel this
is probably one of the more like kind of
complicated ones basically just ask your
coworker for a copy of their code that's
working that has a window function and
then just like plug things in and out
until it kind of works for you but what
it allows you to do is if for exists
example
let's say we have 12 utility statements
for customers we want to sort them by
date and we want to get the second
newest utility statement so here we have
another one of those nested queries
query within the query where we go ahead
and we kind of rank over this statement
date ordering it descending from newest
oldest as the statement rank so
basically every statement gets a rank of
1 2 3 4 5 all the way to 12 and then
from that we select just the one that's
the second one
so basically allows you to kind of
create a coding and a ranking and a
numerical ranking of things based on
other columns in your data set its ends
up being pretty useful and then finally
with all things it's about reporting so
if you're reading this stuff into R then
you can use you know ggplot or markdown
whatever your favorite ways of reporting
things are another really useful thing
of doing it in sequel is that if let's
say you have tableau or some other bi
tool that you like using a lot of them
can just ingest that sequel directly in
so you can go ahead and just like write
your queries up and then take that same
query put it in tableau and then you
never have to do anything again because
the view will just be updated as your
database is update as well and then
finally of course the obligatory like
Excel outputs as well always needed for
managers for anyone who you know doesn't
want to live in your our sequel universe
and I have three little tabs here that I
would encourage you to do in your Excel
outputs you know have a summary or
high-level takeaways have your actual
raw data in case somebody wants to
filter it and play with it and then
actually put your code in there put your
sequel code it's gonna look kind of
janky but it's gonna really improve
reusability when you have to communicate
with your future self six months from
now or it's gonna really improve that if
you have to share and collaborate with
colleagues and others or simply just
rerun the analysis the next week when
your team member asks you for it so what
are some differences kind of
synthesizing what we've talked about and
I use the word off in here but you could
also say sometimes or Never
I mean like I don't know like you can do
all these things and all these things as
Tommy was saying like right now just
like with memory on computers like these
becomes less of a problem but you know
there are huge data sets out there that
you maybe want to combine together and
do that before you bring it into our so
that's maybe a useful use case for some
sequel stuff
similarly you know if you have tons of
columns and you want to run like a lot
of these frequencies of like five or six
seven or ten variables the same time I
find sequels pretty useful for that and
then this fourth bullet about sort of
ease of understanding is important on
the sequel side often if you're like in
a product company like me you work a lot
with engineers and product folks who can
understand and think and breathe in
sequel because it's kind of this lowest
common denominator so even though you
might write out the best like prototype
version and are of what you want
ultimately to be in a production
engineer might not want to look at our
or if they do you know you have to like
really explain though this is a weird
package it came from this place it does
this thing and you have all these
dependencies and stuff so sometimes just
modeling what you want to do and handing
it over in sequel is a way to kind of
interface then I'm sure there's many
more reasons here I give them an hour
conference that are is better I'm sorry
there's only two bullets but like in
your mind just like add lots more
bullets that I'm forgetting here but are
is often better for you know modeling of
course more sophisticated clustering and
other like data summarization all the
extensible packages that are there and
then reporting whether it's through our
markdown or things like that and then
what are some really sweet similarities
that bring it together you know they're
both syntax and code to manipulate
tabular data stored in memory you can do
those seven common tasks that I listed
before in both of them pretty easily
they have a lot of built-in functions
dat arithmetic other things that make it
useful and easy to work with you can
create new functions within both of them
you can like have as much white space as
you want and lots of tabs and new lines
and all that stuff to make it as
parsimonious or as spaced out as you
want and then they're great IDs that
that make it a lot better to to transact
with and to work with and see the
highlighting and all that stuff and then
you can like with both of them export to
variety of formats to work with further
so that's it thanks a lot
you
[Applause]